bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo io sono felice io ci siamo
subito un po particolare come avevo
promesso a tutti quanti voi per la gioia
della community oggi facciamo un video
anche col giugno ho voluto fare una roba
strano io voglio giocatori sentiamo da
un po cosa che volevo dirvi abbiamo
organizzato stupido o ad cazzo
parliamo un po di chi è più spiegato tra
l'uno e l'altro però solo beth ditto ok
io e lui non ci siamo mai parlati di
persona quindi non è anche in chat e
quindi questo video che vedrete il
nostro primo incontro adesso ce ne se si
sta registrando e lui ancora non è
entrato in team stick quindi che cosa
voglio fare appena entrerà in chat
io gli dirò ciao giunge riguarda gli
storage in più sto registrando cioè
della serie non me ne frega un ca di
conoscerti non è vero scherzi non ci
siamo mai parlati e in questo momento
lui entrerà e gli dirò che sto già
recando voglio vedere che cosa dice
eccolo qua stai bene cioè male realtà va
beh chi se ne frega l'importante che
facciamo le più che dai segnato segnato
come si fa attraverso gli ho fatto
questo video perché volevo confrontare
le nostre i nostri esseri quando hai
dato il primo bacio io l'ho dato molto
tardi quindi facciamo un confronto su
starò nonché chi non rivedeva barca non
kg da chi lo dà prima di figo però
volevo capire se ci ho messo più tempo
io se ci hai messo di tempo più asciutto
parti dicendomi se se effettivamente tv
non sia esatta cp per i cui poi dio in
realtà non ha voglia di metodo perché fa
un partita da timidissimo io su youtube
proprio non mi faceva vedere anche in
faccia permanenza in generale chi si ero
il classico ragazzino che si metteva in
fondo nell'ultimo barco per noi vicina
al muro perché loro mi protegge
poi ovviamente youtube ha aiutato
tantissimo c'è una cosa che consiglio ai
numeri e di aprirsi un canale anche
utilizzarlo così for fun capitoli
metterseli e si senza impegno però
questo poi tagliata con questo è vero
questa roba non sia sempre anche io mi
aiutato un sacco ma sono ancora molto
timido ma rispetto a prima un abisso fin
da tipo di dubbio se adesso ci sono
magari qualche appuntamento mi è
capitato di essere quello meno timido
dei due è capito che fa stranissimo
considerando il finale in passato che
sta roba appuntamento che 13 anni fa non
è che prima facevamo è sì sì vai leo
bacio allora c'è quello classico gioco
della bottiglia che avevo fatto
dipende se per te vale dipende se per te
vate elio da raccontare in un video
diciamo che per me valeva per lei no
paolo e sagomata che ti devo fare io
però che tra deve essere sincero al 5
per cento sincero al 100 da 100 quanto
ti aiuta youtube la pa ma c'è tra le
ragazze e ben sarei ancora vergine se no
è vero adesso non sincero non ho
particolari che se non fosse per questo
c'è allora via prima ragazza l'ho
conosciuta grazie a youtube cioè era una
mia iscritta ma proprio ci avevo 6 mila
iscritti
e ancora come hai fatto dei video esatto
e poi seguito da lei per maicon seguiva
ti ringrazio e quindi proprio grazie a
quel se non fosse stato per quello non
avrei mai neanche avuto quella lì poi
magari non sarei rimasto single tutto
questo tempo poi mai dire mai
per carità però è proprio c'è proprio
questa motivazione fini non ti so dire
quanto mi ha aiutato per ora sono stato
solo quel ragazzo che mi seguivano però
in modo molto distaccato perché non
saprei stare con una fan c'è proprio con
una ragazza che dice
ma mia famiglia in un nuovo video non
impossibile
e pare che gli è costato hai salvato la
partita lo so entra entrava dentro è
completamente quindi bravo quindi sì
grazie a youtube
praticamente è successo tutto questo
sono a zero e invece proprio aiutato ora
ritiro prego tg1 la faccio io la
relazione toccate non ce la faremo mai
ragazzi la partita interminabile e ora
che chi segna vinto qua non sappiamo
assolutamente no quindi è pensato
potesse fare nola bastonava bravo
bravissimo 54 la mette lui la decide il
giudice però gli salva la partita il
video o solo una volta mi è capitato in
realtà da qualcuno che ho scritto la
ragazza ora dato che comunque mi seguiva
quindi ero atti o anche più sicuro di
vera e quale è iscritto perché questa
cosa importante è tipo da una ragazza
che sa chi sono che mi segue e mancata
non saprei come dire ciao sono parigi e
jamie green già come fai a stato molto
carina in realtà e
però diciamo che non è una scusa era la
verità in pratica però un mio amico
voleva fare sto video aveva questa idea
di fare la top five iscritte e iscritti
più belli non so perché ho idea
malatissima io ovviamente non l'ho fatto
poi perché era troppo veramente una roba
di uomini e donne si era tristissima
come tagliato va bene gigi bravissimo ma
vengono fatto nulla però dai confusione
la legge basta davvero no non l'abbiamo
fatto però c'era ovviamente perché noi
da sempre conosciamo questa scritta
molto molto bella quindi abbiamo pensato
cazzo
facciamo una classifica dove siamo le
note scritte più belle e ci inseriamo
anche i maschi magari chi lo sa sì è una
cosa 3 scissi anche si sa che per
fortuna non abbiamo mai fatto pesare
questa ragazza b a mio avviso bellissima
ma deve capire che occupare io ho fatto
una cagata leva molto molto bella e
quindi le ho scritto insomma per dirle
se vole a far parte di questo video che
c'è un attimo l'idea è ovviamente
lettonia ha detto di no veramente che
strano sì ha detto è grazie per i
complimenti
però ecco questa cosa la vorrei evitare
per quello non chiedo niente va bene
allora per quanto riguarda l'argomento
ragazze l'abbiamo smarcato ci sarebbe
un'altra cosa da chiede però non la
chiediamo di miss all età di risalita di
quello che penso si 21 ma veramente
marcavano giovedì si è messo malissimo
almeno ora è una domanda da parte
vai vai è una cosa che io ho trattato e
ho fatto
[Musica]
hai mai avuto un periodo proprio di
magra che aveva tanta voglia anche solo
di parlare con una ragazza non è
non aveva occasione quindi sei scaricato
aiutato un sito di incontri hanno un
sito di incontri si rincontrino perché
quando quelle robe tipo tender si sono
sono esplose io già abbastanza messo
bene voglio dire che avrei fatto
probabilmente quindi ti dico di sì io
sai perché l'ho fatto più che altro
perché volevo provare per una volta
appunto a conquistarla ya una ragazza
c'è vita da persona normale per di sosta
perdere però però però sai cos'è ecco io
questa cosa me la chiede ogni tanto se
dovessi mai usare un sito di conti come
facce come fai anche tu cosa fai metti
la tua foto qui 1 la pro potrebbero
pensare che sia un fake o due
comunque non è paura che la gente ti
iscrivi la serie ingiunge cerca sul
figlia ma abbastanza efficace la fiera è
una cosa normale è una cosa che mi parli
del nostro la nostra epoca ci si fa
assolutamente un ottimo ragionamento era
per capire come la vede no io sono stata
cioè vele anche giocare sosta tranquilla
possibile
così tranquillo altri sul suo canale
penso sia nessuno vabbè allora
e perché stai facendo questa cosa lo
stai facendo adesso perché in generale
lo fai quando ti capitava di tender
decenni e no in generale dico perché
così in questa situazione mai chiesto
perché hai avuto questa situazione
perché mesi fa mi è capitato e mi sono
detto sai cosa mi andrebbe di conosce
una ragazza come innesco che il mio nome
piacere e no e non come zumbo capito e
niente poi in realtà dopo un po l'ha
scoperto quindi i cazzi però un po in a1
con la squadra il mio sogno è riuscire
nel mille miglia sogni più reconditi si
dice che non lo so stiamo parlando di
una situazione in cui io sogno di avere
una ragazza che non è italiana e che non
sa che io sono conosciuti in italia che
lo viene a scoprire magari potrà quattro
anni e non so come spiegare ma sarebbe
veramente divertente quella sera vedeva
rappresenterà imbarazzante la vedo come
una roba da film perché la seconda
ascoltare una roba del genere sarebbe
veramente assurdo sarebbe un pò da
stronzi allo stesso tempo però la urbano
mai ce la portiamo che a quella di prima
abbiamo detto no e se a marchio testa
una cosa al punto con questa ragazza che
conobbi su tindari lo tiene nascosto per
un mesetto circa ce la sta facendo
stai facendo e lei aveva un attimo
sospettato che lavorasse appunto del
mondo dell'intrattenimento
dell'intrattenimento di internet
eccetera
finché una sera ho preso una pizza al
trancio ci siamo messi lì per strada
mangiarla a un certo punto arriva questa
ragazza non abbia iscritta e fanno
grandi lotti stimo troppo no ti prego
posso abbracciare di posso darti un
bacio sulla guancia e lei mi ha guardato
malissimo
chissà che cazzo ha pensato in quel
momento era pensato ma questo cioè chi è
questa che arriva così la ex top elena
descrittiva
che non importa quanto quanto tempo ci
mettiate a baciare una ragazza o altro
però alla fine dovete essere pronti voi
deve essere pronto a lei e quindi non
siete sfigate sono i va bè stava
giocando ovviamente quindi si parla di
essere sfigati o meno ma penso che se
sebach è una ragazza 13 anni ho
vent'anni non cambino l'importante le
fate bene è che di trattare bene
ma a gianpi metti un rinoceronte durante
la registrazione a caso durante il video
menti per uno ceronte lo sai che ci sarà
veramente questa cosa sono montatore
video non lo schiavo
[Musica]